très content de vous retrouver en ce 8
mai vous bossez peut-être nous aussi
2h30 ensemble mais oui ça va bien se
passer tes cheveux s'étale comme un
soleil d'été et que tes oreilles
la lumière dessiner sur ton corps et
montagne des forêts et des îles au
trésors
qui n'avait pas de jingle pour
Jean-Pierre Raffin qui a donc décidé
sans aucune raison de chanter du Johnny
et de parler de des Auréliens
ce matin à Paris alors que la voiture du
chef de l'État remonte les
Champs-Élysées ce qui frappe ce sont ces
trottoirs quasi vides les quelques
curieux ont été tenus à bonne distance
pour éviter toute perturbation de ces
cérémonies commémoratives
de la flamme
avec le général de Saint-Chamas qui est
le président du comité de la flamme qui
s'occupe du rivage de la flamme
quotidiennement puisque tous les jours à
18h30 cette cérémonie a lieu
j'invite l'ensemble des Français
parisiens ou d'ailleurs à venir assister
à cette cérémonie qui
qui est très émouvante qui était là ce
matin et qu'on a entendu jusque dans les
Deux-Sèvres
[Musique]
[Rires]
de gaz et gros bisous à plus tard
[Musique]
monter de la mine descendez les collines
camarades
la paille les fusils Habitrail des
grenade
alors le look de Bruno c'est alors c'est
pas possible ce t-shirt c'est pas tu le
trouves et les tatouages avec
les Black bomba le t-shirt des blagues
moi j'investissement bien sûr et c'est
un groupe extraordinaire un groupe
français
c'est des romantiques je fais la bise à
pound d'ailleurs à comment c'est le
chanteur
ceci il a l'air invité blackboard ça
vous changera d'avoir Darmanin tous ces
gens là vous aurez déjà intéressant au
moins tu as de la table
en quoi
à partir de l'automne en octobre
bonjour
de la République
j'ai l'impression qu'on a parlé retraite
là brièvement mais sûrement c'est ce que
vous avez entendu Frédéric aussi
contente de ce que il avait fait pour
les retraites
elle a décidément le sujet qu'on suit le
chef de l'État Nathalie
ce genre de commémoration on peut
imaginer que dans leur quand il leur
pose des questions sur sur eux-mêmes ce
sujet puisse effleurer ou à fleurer
après avoir présidé les célébrations
parisiennes Emmanuel Macron s'est rendu
à Lyon pour rendre hommage à Jean Moulin
à la prison de Montluc où il fut détenu
en 43 c'est dans cette cellule numéro
130 d'appennes 4 mètres carrés qu'il
tente de survivre
et la deuxième c'était la création d'une
arme secrète à l'extérieur et c'est là
tout le paradoxe les manifestants
environ 3000 invoque eux aussi la
résistance
[Applaudissements]
un président de la République quand il
rend un hommage national pour des faits
qui sont extrêmement graves qui sont
uniques dans l'histoire de l'humanité
vous venez pas avec des casseroles je
trouve ça aussi scandaleux et indécent
que les petites cônes qui se prennent et
qui font des selfies à l'entrée
d'Auschwitz
figurez-vous qu'il existe un courant
cinématographique des années 70 vous
n'êtes pas prêt de films érotiques nazis
enfin je veux dire où on voit des nazis
érotiques pendant 2 secondes pour
digérer cette information comment est-ce
que c'est possible que ce soit arrivé
vous êtes peut-être en train de vous
dire je comprends et qu'est-ce que ça
implique tout ça je suis Manon brille et
vous regardez c'est une autre histoire
et aujourd'hui on parle de la nazie
s'exploitation
le 8 mai c'est pas rien c'est la fin
d'un deuxième guerre mondiale la
cérémonie au fort mon luxe c'est là où
était torturé Jean Moulin qui est pour
moi le héros absolu le type qui
verraitablement a donné sa vie pour la
France et c'est là où était enternée les
enfants des yeux etc qu'on aille faire
des casseroles ce jour-là quand le
président va commémorer ça c'est quand
même le jour d'une cérémonie du du
souvenir du recueillement de la mémoire
je trouve ça mais il y a un lien du coup
vous dites peut-être aussi mais pourquoi
s'intéresser à des films qui mélangent
nazisme et érotisme salaire horrible et
qui sexualise un contexte dramatique de
l'histoire et bien parce qu'ils sont
symptomatiques et révélateurs d'une
époque et de la complexité du rapport à
la sexualité d'une part et au passé
d'une autre en particulier lorsque
celui-ci est particulièrement horrible
un déjà je voudrais dire que moi dès que
j'entends la voix de Bruno Le Maire j'ai
une partie de mon corps qui se dilate
c'est comme ça maintenant
depuis que j'ai lu son livre je suis un
peu mieux à chaque fois que
tu te mets à son niveau là
vous avez sûrement dû voir les images
sur les réseaux sociaux ou à défaut
sûrement entendu parler de cette marque
Shein le géant chinois de la mode à très
petit prix l'enseigne a ouvert une
boutique éphémère en plein cœur de Paris
une aubaine pour certains alors que
d'autres dénonces une nouvelle dérive de
la fast fashion
est-ce qu'il faut interdire cette face
fashion elle aurait dû surtout jamais du
s'installer elle devrait pas exister
c'est là c'est oui mais c'est
l'aboutissement le plus ignoble de la
globalisation dégueulasse voilà c'est
c'est un début de fin du monde quoi mais
sauf qu'on est arrivé là que ça plaît
que ça marche c'est ça le drame non mais
derrière c'est le projet c'est le projet
chinois derrière Chine c'est l'État
chinois maintenant moi je suis désolé en
particulier je considère que la Chine
est une des grandes menaces pour la paix
mondiale et pour les équilibres mondiaux
y compris environnementaux donc je pense
que on doit combattre
[Musique]